ecco le guardie che ci stanno guardando
con le camere benvenuto
oggi i nuovi tempi pronta vostro
preferito scappare dalla prigione sapete
che noi abbiamo fatto un taxi si è
conquistato dalla prigione questa però è
la più grande di tutti per farla mega
prigione ob ricordate avevamo già
iniziato a scappare da questa prigione
non amiamo a municipio molto
el'aggiornamento quindi sembrano cose
nuove non farà troppo divertente
iniziamo subito prima di iniziare
ovviamente le facevo il bar la mazzata
prendete i box mettetevi comodi perché
questa sarà una super avventura assieme
le pronti via e così già qua nella
prigione questa volta la completeremo
rubata dovremmo problemi a uscire dalla
prigione il prossimo mio foto qua
c'è una mia foto in spiaggia anche di me
c'è una mia foto in spiaggia non è qui 9
io ognuno come stessa è ok perché questa
buca indicando l'indice di spostare il
battersi ma
non mi ricordavo che fosse così allora
l'hanno proprio aggiornato ma ora questo
ora è la mia cella spetta seno delle
patatine le ram e
questi sono altri altri prigione e
vitale già scappato sono usciti per
locali non è stato vicino al cibo siamo
al livello 1
sotterranei
e così per fortuna non solo dalla porta
a me ricordo che lì c'è il palloncino ma
l'azione balestracci
ma che succede se mi avvicino a
pauroso 6 andiamo vediamo chi ha bisogno
di lottare prima
che cosa mi sembra che abbiamo scavato
troppo in profondità ora siamo nelle
miniere o pensano cadere giù
chi vuole tenere il conto degli
sfracella menti di vitale nuovo lungo
basterà così bravo da tenere il conto
poi scrivetecelo nei commenti
vabbè io devo superare
adoro queste trombe una delle mie
preferite in assoluto è fatta benissimo
è vero anche se la giornata a sé la
musica sia smart è insomma è bellissima
infatti sono super curiosa di vedere
come finisce perché la scorsa volta mi
sembra che siamo arrivati solo a livello
20 ma questa volta dobbiamo arrivare
no io mi aspetta qui vediamo che dice
abbiamo colpito la lava e così caldo qui
abbiamo colpita la lava
ogni tanto le traduzioni di rob lowe
sono tipo google translate lei dove
credi di andare a vincere perché tu hai
la tutina da carcerato io invece il mio
outfit io il mio vestitino rosa che dico
questo vedete tutte fragole
e io invece ho proprio la maglietta
arancione come quella ragazzina
le presenta la vediamo le sfide che tra
l'altro poi ci sono le guardie che ci
guardano dalle telecamere
dovremo stare super attenti anche alle
guardie che ci guardano e le guardie che
ci guardano allora forse dobbiamo
saltare
tutto meno che ha detto
non mi ricordo come funzionava questo
non lasciare che il laser di veloci
partito che nasconde timba
via
ciao ciao ciao
guarda e se guardi nella fine del genere
ci sono io lì che ti aspetta
ma allora devo aspettare che passino
ok
troppo vicini da
grattacieli ei mazzini l'equilibrio qua
eh sì senso che è strano prima nazione a
tutte queste cose sembra che pure quello
o no per lei una pioggia tipo di una
sorta di tossico ma tocca sbriga ei
laser qualcuno
al pavimento e lava che le rime a
pugnale laser
invece la mia nuova pettinatura con le
codine e dovere andando alla storia
mondo ciao ciao
[Applauso]
che cosa si è già uscita non lo so
perché mi è tornato e impossibile che
siamo già fuori dalla cella non so
perché non ha scritto fuori dall'alberto
c'è qualcuno qui no non mi tiro su un
labirinto riguarda questa ventata staff
questa uscita di ventilazione forse c'è
qualcosa che possiamo fare per
distruggerlo
allora qui c'è un pulsante rosso ok by
brevi lo premuto
è esploso
ok è stato per me un pulsante per
distruggerlo bene e quando era la
pentola lisciandra quei bravo a non
presentare o no le guardie ecco le
guardie che ci stanno guardando con le
camere
hanno dato l'allarme ci hanno
fotografato di spalla
ma no non chiuso tutto lo sapevamo che
la futura
scappati quindi che dobbiamo fare adesso
i denti che si fanno scappare
velocissimamente anno è scattato un
allarme
assicuri nemmeno un amico assicura di
non segnare quel versetto laggiù da
quelle stesse le prende ok lì c'è un
poliziotto che sta dormendo per fortuna
si è accorto che quando io che renda che
parte premia questa parte
sui social card il poliziotto stato
ormai lo prendi la carta preso detto
[Musica]
hanno dato l'allarme al poliziotto dorme
mattina potranno guardare tutte le cose
penso che volevo dire anch'io se
dobbiamo tornare dovere monzillo perché
abbiamo perso la porta preghiamo si
stima che siano più che gli abbiamo
rubato la chiave è quello che era la
porta questa segue ma gli altri non si
sono accorti che abbiamo per tenere
forte perché attivato i pavimenti laser
non possiamo lasciarla scappare il
prigioniero e alberi e se ne sono
accorti che siamo
ma tanto noi laser non ci perdono d
alema lorenza loro la mensa si è
allagata qualcuno si è sfracellato e
aspettami è arrivato al 91 scappata
keegan e la polizia
jack ora almeno credo
altri laser
e dirò prima io bambino
vi sta arrivando che dice lì che il
corridoio a sinistra un vicolo cieco
quindi dobbiamo andare più a destra ma
abbiamo un ricco non si è domandato di
qua
ma anche non si va da nessuna parte
periodo siamo soli reso si apparta
grande questa prigione che c'è una prima
revisione sapranno già trovato
stanno sparando un nota non c'era
l'altra volta mi ha mai fatto i provini
l'hanno proprio cambiato aggiornato
attenti alle forbici in forno sparando
contro sbrigati salire sul terrazzo
laggiù dovrebbero esserci questo spero
di no di non peccare in fare
ok cifrato c'è un fatto vitale ha
superato in
convento successo allora che si fa
saltare sul razzo e ma perché si è
bloccato tutto come si attivano
clicca
per chi infatti come giornalista
carroccio bene ei aspettami dobbiamo
stare insieme ma io lo prendo subito
fatto ciao
solo sul razzo e ora questo caso è un
viaggio di sola andata verso la luna
quando verso la luna ma come abbiamo
fatto solo scappare dalla prigione non
chieda se arriviamo comune
ops
siamo arrivati sulla luna
stiamo senza tutela beh sembra ci siamo
spiantate sulla luna abbiamo una bassa
gravità permettiamo di uscire da questo
posto
molto bene che l'hanno cambiando molte
questi giorni mentre qua nei crateri
dentro
ecco perché la gravità ci fa saltare in
alto la branca di grazia in teoria
dovremmo volare e dove sei tristellato
sto solo sto volando nel nuoto
queste sono quelle qui bisogna correre
sono super divertenti ma a volte sono
troppo
divertenti
ciao io mi sono salvato sta arrivando e
letto dove sei finito di fatto ora si
tira giù che vorrebbe fondare piano
perché qua vicino
sì ma cos'è sta storia è bravo e sa
stare su quei cartelli non solo rosa
ecco
che cos'è un omino che ci dice che
dobbiamo entrare nella bassa spazio
spaziale si la base lunare sulla testa
dentro così possiamo essere
teletrasportati sulla terra beh ancora
un è stato bello ma è già finita nostra
avventura sulla luna e così siamo
arrivati siamo tornati in prigione dalla
realtà ma torna di prigione nostri erano
di nuovo sulla terra ma ci sono mine
antiuomo cui fuori assicurarsi di non
toccarli a me questi sembrano l'ex
capo lecca lecca stupro voluto di
piccole
camerun ha
guardato
partito
a non toccarle ma sei sempre pensando a
prendere cose da mangiare
ci credo
chi manderebbe no
poi dobbiamo correre qua la faremo ma
perché non riesco perché ce l'ho fatta
ho resto noi uno dei laser che vitale ci
sono ancora le camere sono state quasi
mai in bagno è nota ma non possiamo
uscire dobbiamo per forza pastore dal
bagno nel frattempo che è vitale
langella in laser noi
se non sbaglio
e rimandare il minor me è in atto il
criminologo mattino maglia ma allora non
capisco dove siamo finiti perché non
finito che lei sorrideva è per quello
che abbiamo il cappello che il capo
dello speleologo vedete che ci sono gli
scheletri dei prigionieri è noto che
cosa ci succederà forse siamo vicini
all'uscita
attento ma bisogna esaltarsi l'esatte
battere insomma sanatorio vittorio pio e
poi via e poi via poi non ho capito come
fare prendiamoci lo spettacolo sanitario
che si accellera dieci volte mi chiamo
ero solo però allora proviamo a prendere
un po di rinforzi di tutto dai fatti
dove tra l'altro ha tenuto non ci
pronunciamo foto di creare anche io
salviamo e questi sembrano i tubi di
super mario quindi l'hanno cambiata ogni
ato per ato idrici e questo che succede
dobbiamo scappare su una dobbiamo
aspettare una delle zattere e salire su
una delle zattere e veloce però a
giudizio una zattera qua eccola by no
non l'ho vista
da 3 o prendi la prossima non ho visto
che succeda niente niente stavo cadendo
c'è una piccola discesa ma non cadrà il
capitale se vendiamo seccare dalle
zattere
non c'è una rapida non aveva affermato
che rimuovere aspetta allora puoi
saltare
livello 4 tetti
interessante resteremo siamo i ruoli
insistiamo sul tetto stai attento a
queste luci sono tipo i fari che usano
per cercarci la poesia è in allerta
risicata la polizia è in allerta insomma
ci stanno cercando questi pari
potrebbero prenderci carci e trovarci
quindi dobbiamo andare queste luci
ok è riuscita a facebook io o no vi
ricorda che quando era diviso non riesce
mai a dall'elicottero tra l'altro
l'elettricità l'elettricità qua è
esposta quindi se la tocchi sei morto no
non toccare nessuno di questi cavi
cavour
tanto vedo la carcassa di vita no anche
due però devo dire che rispetto ad
un'altra volta siamo diventati più bravi
la prima volta che abbiamo provato
l'escape room se vedete i nostri primi
video di rho blocks eravamo delle
schiappe soprattutto vitale bene prima
di salire sull'elicottero vediamo
bisogna solo in digitale che si
sfracella non per andare con
l'elicottero story ma dai che aspettano
vediamo quanto ci metterai ad arrivare
qua
dobbiamo fare una canzoncina con
dell'espresso e la 20th vitale hai
superato quello in cui si sfracella vi
sempre
te puoi farcela cui farcelo
permettere di stato dove si metterà
sulle ricotta
livello 5 atterraggio schianto si sono
schiantati con l'elicottero di vincolo
che si schiantavano non laurin ottica
ciao battuti piano via traversa quelle
linee elettriche laggiù quindi bacio
ragazzo ti sei stato per dire non c'è il
problema ecco evitare la giornata starei
molto attento del roller vuoti sfracelli
o ti prendono vedi che sono raggio che
si aspettano sembra abbastanza semplice
più che si
disse quello che si sposa alloggio
proposta creativa i piani valdiano
velocissimo
i fratelli io mi sento sei fogli
pacchetto carbonio e pensi di qua ho
sentito qualcuno è stato celato se non
mi ricordo male poi c'era una mancherà
lo stesso vediamo ei 26 93 novembre
ancora c'è una scatola giunti a come dai
ti aspetto qui alla scala eccomi qui
andiamo dietro ci siamo siamo fuori se
volessi di scapolari
coniugi hanno ripreso
non in galdo ops
livello 7 prigione di alcatraz
abbiamo fatto tutta questa fuga ma è già
la ripresa se non metto nella prigione
di alcatraz di botti con sicurezza
vediamo che dice ah fantastico siamo
stati mandati ad alcatraz e trovare uno
strumento che ci permetterà di rompere
uno dei servizi igienici o peggio li
segna fa scappare anche noi accettiamo
profitti
allora questo è quello che dobbiamo
cercare di rompere quindi dobbiamo
trovare un piede di porco mi sono
precipitato e trovato pensi veramente
distintivo segreto come io invece ho
trovato di porco vicino a questa quarta
si tramanda dov'è il belgio invece qui e
io qualcosa in questa stanza che
potrebbe aiutarti grazie ma non troppo
il peggio e questo solo tu
stai presto preso ok ora distruggiamo
uno dei bagni per scappare prima
che succede
io sono un forno il segreto del ponente
26 sono scappata dal tunnel e e ora dove
tutto pensiamo pure piede di porco me lo
tengo casomai vi può servire ma attento
a non cadere qui a una scivolata che
sembra ci sia la lava sotto ecco
dovrebbe essere qua la via d'uscita
vediamo si livello 8 tubazioni di un
botto ma crediamo che ci dice ci sono
delle trappole in questa questo livello
nella dopo la ventola un pochettino
pericolo fatta a
quello dell'età no perché attenta il
pavimento si muove pure si è riuscita
no quasi non ho aperto il mio piede di
porco
aiuto aiuto
mi
aspetterà tubazioni
tubature
tubature procedimento
dai puoi farcela abitare contiamo su di
sé non mi piace per portare fortuna
abitare la7 mi piace ha detto qui diamo
ultimo set
una interessante questa parte quindi se
carità in dritta ottimo meglio non
cadere in un piano piano piano
mi raccomando kenney l'equilibrio e se
ci sono gli hai fatto a caso stiamo
dentro le tubature sto male io metto
solo il tubo aykroyd
siamo siamo in una in una cella no
sembra un ragazzino si è riuscito ad
uscire jolie ci sono le camere altri
laser o non ha bisogno di nuovo doppio
di poco non lo so attento ai laser
fatto guarda qua c'è un tritatutto c'è
un pulsante attiverò fare
bisogna premere il pulsante premo il
pulsante
pulsante blocca tutto si no per adesso
ok
non devi mai portato tra territorio di
strateghi del mondo no devi premere noi
di rilassarlo
aspetta suo passato di nome faceva il
materiale radioattivo attento a non
toccarlo noi ci siamo quasi
finalmente avrò il pezzo della prigione
di hobby fatto in questo cancello che ci
potrebbe essere un'altra porta in questa
stanza forse questa è perché si è potuto
quindi devo tornare indietro sembra gli
ato le porte farina aspetta aspetta
vediamo c'è quella porta lì
forse questa porta veniamo signora
quella
batteria elettrica
no non si può rigati ok qui passa la
strada
quello che trovo uno non è quello
centrale dobbiamo scegliere una delle
tre ma voi mi avete insegnato il
trucchetto e cioè guardare
e non aveva ancora bene
ho fatto prima io sto parlando mentre un
folto giorni e adesso è quello di destra
secondo me sì e poi conosciamo non è
quello centrale
proviamo questo
manca l'ultimo
questi si passa attraverso ed è quello a
sinistra si è opposto il laser qui se ti
passa anche da far loro vedere
pronti a passare con tutti i love
piano
e decollare il braccio e l'incredibile
asti motivo una nella mensa ora ci
facciamo un
continuo ma si muovono no no non si
muovono ci sono anche sopra le realtà
non saltate troppo in alto
ok ce l'ho fatta e ora sono
giganti a bisogna
evitarli
lo dicono
chiaro chiaro
a entrambi
ok stai molto attento ed io sono pronto
a
livello 10
poi siamo riusciti arrivare il cortile
quando dei prigionieri con il miglior
comportamenti più bravi possono
entrare qua noi siamo i più bravi siamo
più bravi perché siamo riusciti aspetta
riusciti a scappare quasi si sta
impegnando
ma che io non c'è una volta qui forse
riusciamo a scappare da qui vediamo
che succede c'è una guarda che mi ha
beccato a nole non posso passare queste
reti con tante mi metto solitario
non so mi sono libero di
contenimento
e questo ci stanno un poliziotto ci ha
messo fuori con un dardo dormienti ora
sono messo in isolamento veloce e robbie
quel muro la zuppa o carini perché
questo c'è stato il manzo c'è anche la
camera
ok sbrighiamoci prima che se ne vada
proprio in atto che ormai siano molto
arrabbiate queste guardia perché siamo
scappate da tuscia vostra preda
l'isolamento devono gestire passiamo
allora ci sono altri laser cui dai
veloce lontani come si apre questa porta
aperta siamo nelle mura della prigione
quindi per fascisti nella palestra di
voti non si sa perché nella roma però
macellato attento e difficile qua per
non può di rincorsa ma
vediamo vitale dai due bar ce la
facciamo tanto solo nel nuovo se è
ancora vivo come fosse affatto come puoi
farcela e super difficile
ci stai po di beffa
perché esaltato e solo camminato joe
prestito prima che se ne accorgano via
più vividi e di qua di nuove ma no ma no
a dire che dobbiamo uscire nelle
fognature
no penso che questa sia la spiaggia
grazie a un altro in cotto cosa
scopriamo ci siamo ci stiamo dobbiamo
essere delle persone importanti se
abbiamo tempo nelle coppe bene tra un
elicottero così riusciremo a trovare
vedevo dirò ma che dovrebbe essere per
scoprono le foto
personale ma è riuscito a salire
[Risate]
il badge il bench devo assolutamente
prendere belli portato a nove livelli
c'è scritto aspetta ma c'è una piazza
per una piscina la siamo meritata e poi
aspetta forse l'ho perdonato guarda c'è
scritto devo scoprire la prigione
radiouno il network air per i nostri
premi ok
non sarà mica sarà mica un altra
o video il premio della mischia foto
dalle prigioni venga hobby si è stato
troppo divertente riguarda il nostro
nauta vuoi andare sulla luna nuova
che vogliamo fare un altro direttore la
luna come prima caffettiera divertente
ma non abbassiamo nella luna sulla luna
il terrazzo st bruno e fantastica stand
un sacco di cose basta
ora giochiamo in un modo rocker la vita
è rivolto a terra infatti per una
persona vedi
in italia le dovrebbe essere l'italia è
quella non non si capisce poi ho fatto
male
ma questo è un altro gioco
piuttosto ma
perché c'è meno gravitano
se questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace però questo già fatto la luna è
stato troppo di per bellissimo si sono
contati ma ho rifatto e poi è completata
soprattutto ora vi lasciamo 48022
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
buona visione